we've been joined now on the phone by
sharon osbourne who uh actually i think
was a talk tv presenter of course was
actually at the albert hall uh yesterday
where jeff beck was playing and knows
johnny depp sharon uh what do you make
of the verdict
um wow it wasn't what i was expecting i
mean i wanted johnny to win but i wasn't
expecting him to
you've been you know
um
i was gonna say sharon i mean i've known
you and aussie a long time you've spoken
very honestly before about toxic times
in your marriage over the years mutually
abusive and so on
what did you make of the case here what
did you make of both sides did you did
you did any of it resonate with you that
it was just a toxic relationship and
unlike you and aussie who did resolve
everything
they they couldn't
it's
for me it was um i related to it
so much
and you know i i know alcoholic behavior
inside out and backwards
and it's alcoholic behavior but you know
they were both abusive both very very
abusive to each other and at any time
she could have left and she wasn't a
little raw flower you know she was a
mover and shaker in town i mean look who
she went with right after him
so she wasn't some innocent little wall
flower she knows the game she knows how
it goes and the situation is you know
now i mean after listening and hearing
about all their dirty laundry
you know she
i some of my as a woman i feel badly for
her because every penny she earns is
going to go someplace not in her bank
account
right i mean this is i mean this is not
an insignificant i mean this is 15
million i'm not even sure that she has
money remember remember she's got to pay
the tax on that too so double it
right i mean this is it's a huge it's a
huge disaster for her isn't it um in
terms of johnny depp a huge huge and
sharon do you think johnny with your
manager hat on
is there a way back now for johnny depp
if he'd lost this i think his hollywood
career was done but has he been so
damaged in the process of not just this
case but the libel action against the
sun hearing in which he lost of course
has he been so damaged by the
revelations that it's almost impossible
now to put him back in a big movie
no it's not impossible and everybody
loves to come back and the thing is
this his case before was in england this
was done in front of an american jury
and i think that he's going to get his
career back
yeah i mean i really do i think you know
i think that all the great big
filmmakers will want johnny because now
they've seen listen when it comes down
to it it's how strong an audience do you
have and johnny depp has a huge
worldwide audience and there's no doubt
also
there's no doubt that he won on in the
court of public opinion on social media
was massively in favor of johnny depp
now some might argue that it got it got
it got very vicious towards amber heard
and i'm not sure that that is ever a
good thing in fact monica lewinsky has
written a big piece of vanity fair
tonight talking about this turning into
kind of courtroom porn we're all gorging
on the entrails of this divorce
but you know there's always people out
there that want to be vicious about
people they don't even know it's
perception not reality and you know
you're always going to get your haters
that come out and want to have a voice
but the thing is johnny
you know he's got a huge price on his
head the world loves him
the world loves him so you know the
world really did want him to win and
he's won and that's it she could have
she could have you know
backed out somehow she could have got to
him there could have been something to
say that's going on they could have
because he is he would have
he wouldn't have gone this far if she if
she
you know didn't push and push and push
and she won the case in england but yet
she wanted more well yeah i mean
technically
technically she wasn't involved in that
england case he sued the son for libel
and lost but she was the kind of
secondary winner because they concluded
that he had abused her this is a big big
case in america
yeah
i mean i think and the other thing about
it
i was going to say the other thing about
this is that you know for amber heard
she's an actress but i don't think she's
going to get any work after this is she
because the jury actually concluded but
she acted with malice in other words
she has deliberately lied here about him
to damage him
listen she's lied she was in the court
in england and she lied under oath in
england when she said that she'd given
her seven million to charity and she
hadn't and elon musk had made a donation
under her name of a pittance of what it
should have been
so she lied under oath so that wasn't
looking good for her and and the thing
is no i don't think that any big film
studio will touch her right now
just finally sharon you know johnny you
know johnny depp sharon um you know a
lot of people whose opinion i respect
you know joan collins and catherine
jenkins a singer whose husband made
johnny's last movie they talked very
highly of him and believed that he was a
victim of a miscarriage of justice
throughout all this process and tonight
i'm sure are feeling very happy for him
but for those who don't know johnny depp
what is he like
he's he is a gentle soul i can tell you
last night piers he spent about 45
minutes in his dressing room on his
knees talking to this little girl that
was reading her diary to him
now i don't know many guys that would
sit there and do that there weren't any
cameras around there were no film crews
he did it because he's the gentle soul
he wanted this little girl to read the
diary to him and she did she must have
been all of eight years of
age and the thing is he is a gentle soul
but we know what alcohol and drugs do
when you mix them together they change
you
so you know sometimes i suppose you know
he lost his rag but as a human being
he's a good human being
sharon really appreciate you calling in
uh thank you very much indeed it's it's
a dramatic night certainly uh for all
the people involved in this and you
bring a great perspective thank you very
much
all right thanks my darling bye
you